hello everyone
welcome to this webinar we're going to
be starting in just a few more minutes
and today is actually the first session
of the source code 2 training program
with lbrn
so i'm glad to see everyone here
all right hello mohit i guess we should
start it's
10.
yeah hi elia hello everyone okay sorry
for the delay
i was just setting up the zoom
okay hello everyone how's everyone doing
yeah we will start in a minute
let me share my screen
uh elia can you see my screen no
no not yet yeah now now we can see it
yep great
okay
so hello everyone welcome to today's
session today we have the first session
on uh the program for kobe 19 and
in this program we will be discussing
several aspects
and today in this session i will start
with
uh discussing about the program in brief
and then we will learn about uh yourself
like if you have done gone through the
registration process
if you have uh gone through the
resources that we have been sharing
so uh today we will also discuss
uh on the later part of this
presentation um
the application of ngs data for
for for the application of understanding
the different aspects of uh kovi 19
genomic analysis so just one second
my presentation seems to be stuck just a
second sorry for this
guys
okay so um
here maybe i should then take it from
here
sorry just some problem with the
presentation is
like i'll just take a couple of minutes
maybe meanwhile we can
help uh who have joined to go through
the
learn registration okay
okay yeah so let me share a couple of
things um
so welcome everyone this session is the
first session so we're going to be going
through some of the basic things but
before we do that
i'll let mohit kind of figure out what's
with the slides
let us go through some of the major
topics that this program is intended to
address
and briefly talk about how you can get
started with the program itself
and get yourself into the content that
we've prepared for the program
so first of all the topic of this
program is really
sars cove 2 as an extraction
of a program that we have regularly
called
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
so sarskoff ii is an unusual virus
in the sense that it has turned very
quickly into a pandemic that has spread
around the world
but also we are living at a time
where for the first time in history the
data about the genomic characteristics
of this evolving virus
is being made available almost in real
time
so if you're following the news and you
don't live in a cave
on mars you hear about this all the time
and what we know today
is that the general public
is being so aware of terms that just a
few years ago
anyone would just ignore completely what
are mutations
what are variants of concern what is the
difference between the variant of
concern
and an actual mutation that has some
pathogenic
consequence what are the different
immune responses right so all of these
topics are
being discussed by the broad public
and it is important we think for us to
focus on
the aspect of bioinformatics in this
program
so that anyone that has some
appreciation for the molecular biology
and the pathology of this disease
can actually base their opinions and
their findings
on data and so that is really the
objective
of this program okay so again for those
of you that are joining today
the first thing that we would like to do
is we would like to today
introduce you to how you can get started
with
learning about the different types of
data available for
source code 2. how can you understand
what this data really means
and how the interactive sessions that we
are planning for this program
can really help you become proficient
at analyzing this data and asking
important questions that are on
everyone's mind
and so to get started
let us go to the omix logic learn
portal so
let me ask all of you how many of you
already
have registered on this portal
so this is the link i'm putting in the
chat and maybe you can let me know
when you are registering when you're in
you will see your email address right
here so please let me know how many of
you
have already registered you can put it
in chat
just put number one or yes or something
like this
so i'll give it a moment
all right excellent so if you have
already registered
you can click on this
email address and you should see your
profile
so the first thing that we would like to
do today
is to make sure that your profile is
completely set up
and i will show you how this profile can
help you
get into the program and start with the
different material that we will be
covering
now if you haven't registered yet take a
couple of minutes and register
so again once you are registered you
should see your email address right here
on the top
and by clicking on this you will be able
to see your profile
with your profile image
social media links a little bio that you
can add about yourself
and then we will talk today about this
progress tab
as you can see the different activities
that you perform
on this portal are being tracked to
collect information about you
for your own benefits so that you can
track your progress
but also because of the programs that
we're going to be talking about today
okay so once you complete your profile
the next thing that we want to do is we
want to go
right here to the programs tab
and take a look at the program
for stars code 2. okay and so
here is the program page
if you're already a part of this program
you should see what i see on the screen
if you don't see this
you just see a bigger screen with the
title of the program and when it starts
you can see today is july 12th so it's
starting today
you need to still complete your
registration so it's okay if you haven't
completed today
and up until the next session you have
plenty of time to complete the
registration
but i want to start with a few key
points
about how this program is actually going
to work
so the first thing that we will do is
review the history and the
pathogenesis the origin and the
pathogenesis
of this novel coronavirus so then we can
get acquainted
with some of the basics with
where the virus could have come from
based on the available data so what are
some approaches to
analyze this data and ask the questions
about origins
how do we monitor the evolut the
evolution
of this virus to understand how it
changes as it spreads
and then to also look at the responses
to the sarcoscope 2 virus to really
understand
what is the immune component so how does
this virus
cause disease how does that
change between individuals and also
how can we based on our understanding of
the immune responses
intervene so what are some of the
strategies for
drug design vaccine design
how do we think about these
interventions
in the context of what we can see from
data
and so to facilitate that you can see
that down here we have a syllabus
of the program where we will talk about
how viral sequencing is being done which
is the
topic of today's session how we can find
presence of viral genomes in different
types of
animals as we know pangolins bats
even dogs have been suggested to be
susceptible
how we can use existing databases
like ncbi virus and gis
aid to find sequences
how we can find high quality covet 19
genomic data and then how to start
analyzing this data from
the perspective of multiple sequence
alignments
building a phylogenetic tree then
looking specifically for
variants of concern so that we can
track the alpha beta
gamma all of these different strains and
understand how they
evolve and what are the associations
between
different strains and different regions
and what are these variants of concern
that we should be mindful of
now inside of this schedule
you will see links to the zoom sessions
so how this session is organized is that
we will review some of the content that
will be also provided asynchronously
after completing the asynchronous
content you will be able to ask
questions and interact with the mentor
and i will introduce you to the mentor
today
and also you will be able to run
analysis together
so hands-on practical analysis
that will be guided and then you can
look at the results
and obviously check that the results are
correct
so this is the schedule now at the end
of this
the idea of this program is to
allow you to understand where to find
data
understand how you can ask questions of
this data
know how to perform analysis and plan
your analysis according to the question
that you have
using several examples from public
repositories and peer-reviewed
publications
and then potentially to use that to
develop a project of your own
so at the end of this process you will
have a little bit of time
to work on a project of your own which
you can start
right from the very beginning as you
learn about different aspects of this
kind of analysis
okay so maddie does that
answer your question
okay great so
um now as you go down below
okay this is not loading because i'm
sharing my screen
just reload this
okay but included in this
program are some asynchronous resources
and so to talk about the resources
i want to introduce dr harpreet kaur
she will be guiding some of the sessions
and doing some practical
interactive assignments together with
you and so
i will give her the presentation so that
she can talk a little bit about her
background but also to
introduce some of the contents that you
will have access to through the program
dr harpreet thank you ilya
just let me share my
hello everyone my name is harpreet kaur
i have a phd in bioinformatics
currently i am curriculum developer and
research consultant with pan biotech
in my current role i am mentoring number
of the research fellows and assisting
participants from different programs to
learn about data analysis
machine learning visualization in the
application of large data
used in the biomedical research so to
provide
hands-on training and to make
participants familiar
with approach to design and complete a
research project
we are continuously designing different
research projects
using publicly available data
and implementing various bioinformatics
tools which are integrated on our
t band for server so here we have
collection of the research project
where you can learn how
bioinformatics can be applied in diverse
fields
using publicly publicly available data
to drive biological
and clinical significance from the
genomics data
so let me give you a glimpse of one of
the project
that is based on a current pandemic of
the sars scope 2
that is origin of the cobait 19
so as we know whenever a pandemic
outbreak happens
like the current corporate 19 so there
are the several questions that needs to
be answered
these questions can be of any of the
followings for example
where did the noble coronavirus comes
from
which animal what location and how did
it start infecting the humans
so to understand and design the vaccine
against any virus
we need to find answer to these
questions
so to wait towards this in the march
in the march 2020 so anderson at all
have published
a research letter in the journal nature
medicine in which authors
study the proximal origin of the sars
co2
based on the ngs data and they also
find some of the important mutations in
the spike routine
that are responsible for its enhanced
pathogenicity
so based on this study we designed a
research project
so in this project we explored this
pathos and coronavirus itself
as well as the diseases caused by it so
here you will learn
how you can find its origin and how much
it is related with already existing
human corona wireless stream
based on various techniques like
multiple sequence alignment and
phallogenetic analysis
using the publicly available ngs data
next you will learn what are the
important components of the virus
through which they enter into the human
cell we will also look into how much it
is different
from other coronavirus streams like sars
mers etc
at last you will also learn like how you
can identify important signatures that
can significantly different
under therapeutic treatment or untreated
conditions
as as the genomic data continuously
growing so there are a number of the
public repositories that maintain ngs
data for the source code too
for example ncbi collected all all of
the viral genomes from the pandemic
and associated viral sequences of the
like viruses in a new repository which
is called ncvi virus
so during this program we will learn
how to obtain ngs data for the south
scope 2 from these public repositories
using specific keywords like its
location
the host as well as which countries it
belongs
so after downloading the data from the
ncbi
next you will learn how you can perform
multiple sequence alignment
to understand the phylogenetic
relationship between these organisms
so here you will you can learn
its unity reason and you will also learn
how you can compare it with other
existing strains
based on the ngs data
so subsequently you will learn how you
can perform multiple sequence alignment
to understand the mutational changes
that are taking place in starscope 2 in
comparison to the
other stream from different animals as
well as the other corona by the strains
from the human
so you can compare and find out some
important mutation
in a specific protein or a specific
sequence
next you will also learn how you can
analyze
multiple sequence alignment to
understand the differences
and the mutation among different samples
at nucleotide as well as the amino acid
label so you will learn how many
mutations are synonymous
and how many mutations are
non-synonymous
so let me ask one question can anybody
tell me the difference between
synonymous mutations or
non-synonymous mutation
so can anybody tell me the difference
between synonymous
and non-synonymous mutations
so you can post your answer in the chat
box
or let me give you just
a hint so
silence mutation any one of you familiar
with the silent mutations
and mistance mutations
okay so we have answers from the gyra
phenomenal associated with the phenotype
gene
perfect so many is perfectly all right
so synonymous mutation when they does
not affect the amino acid while
non-synonymous mutations
when there is a change into amino acid
yes perfect
so you will learn how many mutations are
actually translated at amino acid level
and how many mutations are remains
synonymous mutation
so the next you will learn what are the
important protein components
in the virus as well as the hosts that
are responsible
for the pathogenicity for instance
how easter receptor winds to the spike
protein
and you will learn how to visualize
structure of the protein and its complex
the
that is ace to spike protein complex
using different publicly available
softwares
so in the subsequent part you you will
learn how you can obtain transcriptomics
data for the patients or the host that
are infected with the sas go to from the
other public repository like geo and sre
okay let me ask one question can anybody
tell me the difference
between sra and the jio
so what kind of data we can find for sra
and what kind of data we can find from
jio
anyone have some idea
like what kind of data let me give you
just hint
jio micro array sra ngs
so exactly not uh maybe let me give you
one hint
so one is pro uh more or less process
data other is
raw sequencing read
raw data one of these repository mainly
maintains
process data and other repository mainly
maintains raw data
sra maintains raw data
okay yes perfect
and yes manos you can ask your question
please
so you can post your query in the chat
box or otherwise you can unmute yourself
can you enable okay so elia can you just
enable or just make uh so that he's able
to unmute himself or you can unmute
yourself i guess
no i mean i think as a co-host you can
probably
unmute him if you need to or
he can just yeah put the answer in the
chat
hello ma'am yes ma'am good evening thank
you so much
i have a question now i am second year
in
a biotechnology subject undergraduate
student
ma'am i want to pursue in future
biotechnology in nsur biomed which is
the better you know
so that depends upon your research
mainly interest so
i think according according to your
research interest or
what is your goal of i mean so
accordingly you can proceed otherwise
uh by bioinformatics and biotech are
saying i think both are equally good
both are uh both are equally good but
which one is better for
me i don't understand that's why i
we can answer that later because it's
more relevant to uh
your work so maybe we can do this later
once the presentation is over
thank you yes we can i think at the end
of the session we will address those
questions
thank you manos
so here you will learn how to explore
this
transcriptomics data from the host to
find out important signatures that are
associated with the drug treatment like
representative similarly you can analyze
such data to understand
how virus cause infection and what are
the some of the
immune response differences between
acute or the mild coping 19 to this
condition
so here you will learn how we can
perform phylogenetic analysis
and let's i think let me demonstrate to
you how we can
use our t band for server to perform
phylogenetic analysis
using ngs data
so let me give you a simple
demonstration
okay so this is the main fluid analyst
analytical platform
and here you will find different
sections
for different types of analysis
depending upon your goal depending upon
your data
so here under the data integration and
the modeling
section you will find this followed in
under the data
association subsection you will find
this module followed in a tree
so here let me
let me just give you this project that
is demo
search go to origin so this is an
example project where we have already
provided the data
so once you able to click on that
then you will direct it to this
interface
so by clicking on the start you will
able to upload the data
so here you will learn what kind of data
is required for example what should be
the format so
like here we have dangerous data in the
fasta format
then how to upload the data so by
clicking on
we will able to upload this data because
this is already
example process so here we need not to
upload data externally
so we had already uploaded data here for
you
then the next option which is
automatically get highlighted
after uploading your data that is
multiple sequence alignment
so it will align your sequence all the
sequences
using cholesterol w tool then
once you have at a sequence alignment
next
is their alignment at the amino acid
label so here the first because in this
example project we have also uploaded
reference genome
with translation codons so why upload uh
clicking on ok
then we will able to perform multiple
sequence alignment at amino acid label
so then we can select a specific codon
position
so eventually you have different methods
to generate phylogeny so here
we ah for example we have a method then
we have waste coalescent
constant size uh based speciation yield
process with speciation with
death process so so here we are using
right now all the methods so we are
selecting this option
all file is any method option
then by clicking on ok we will able to
perform
to generate phylogenetic tree with all
the methods so finally we will
get this option tree space so this is
another module which will generate a
median tree for you
so by clicking on this we able to
generate median tree
then finally by clicking on the end we
will able to complete our pipeline
so then once your pipeline get completed
then under the download output file
so you will get various types of output
now
let me just show you one of the output
here
if i go to the presentation again so
this is the output file that we have
will obtain
so this kind of allergenic tree you will
get so
here you can find out like
you have sequences from different
course for example here we have human
cytoscope 2 pangolin corona virus that
corona virus
red sauce and wet corona virus so then
to
understand what is the phallogenetic or
evolutionary relationship
and for example for this human
sarcophagu
related with other chronovirus strain so
from the based on the phylogeny tree we
can
understand that it is a closely
associated with the
pangolin corona virus
okay repre let me interrupt you for a
second i see a few
questions that maybe we can address
briefly
i think that they are relevant so
um number one for
those of you that have completed the
registration to the program
you will find the link to the slack
channel at the bottom of the program
page
so if you're not a part of the program
that's why you're not
on the slack channel if you're already a
part of the program
then please find it at the bottom of the
page again i can just uh
demonstrate where that would be just one
second let me
share my screen so that you know as
you're following along
okay so here's the page if you scroll
all the way down
right here if you click on this ask
question
you will be taken to the slack channel
and then it will open right here in
slack
okay so if you
live livia if you have completed the
registration
are you logged in can you see your login
information
uh okay maybe you can share your
profile id and i will take a look
so if you click right here
this whole url
that is what i need okay anyone else
that also
has completed the registration or has
registered through lbrn
and you don't have access to something
just post your link right here and we
will check
during today's session now the other
question that we had here
um can you use the t by info platform to
access files saved on gcp
google cloud or aws amazon web services
clouds yes
any cloud-based link that you can share
with
an ftp or https you can actually
you can share that okay so olivia looks
like you're
a part of this program so if you go to
your page
okay so i think this is the older one
so let me take a look at this and just
double check your
account
okay for any questions about publicly
stored data yes you can use it
using https links or ftp links
if you want to download sra files from
ncbi
you can use that directly as well we
will go through that
in the program sessions okay so
back to you uh dr harpreet i will check
her account now
thank you
okay so for example this phylogenetic
tree shows that
humans are scoped too genome sequences
are more closer to the pangolin
than to wet corona virus so that's
depending upon the data that we have
used in this project
so if you're interested
if you are interested in getting started
with such analysis
on your own and already you are
registered so i recommend
you to going on the learn platform and
how you should start different courses
now let's go over learn platform
so the first lesson i would recommend
you you
if you are very much new to the biology
in the bioinformatics first
course that you must go through that is
why it's in the molecule
now let me share its link with you so if
you are already existed you will be able
to access this lesson
if you have yet to register then please
go ahead with your registration
and then you can start this courses
so this is the first course that i would
recommend you you should start
and then once you complete this course
then move to the next
course that is introduction to the
bioinformatics
so let me share its link with you so
especially this course is for those
who are not not from the bioinformatics
background so that you understand what
are the important applications
of the bioinformatics and we will also
learn what's your background
so here you need to submit one of the
forms so based on which we learn what's
your background so that we can
accordingly guide you
so the next course once you have
completed these two introductory course
then to understand how you can do
different genomics data analysis once
you have the ngs data
so the next course that i would
recommend you that is genomics
so here you will learn the basics as
well as the advance of the genomics so
you will find
understand how to find data the genomics
as well as
what types of analysis you can perform
for the genomics data
so once you have completed this course
then i would recommend you
this particular process that we already
talked about
so that is project coven 19 origin and
pathogenesis of sasco 2.
so these are the courses you must start
like first complete
white cell molecule then introduction to
the bioinformatics then
complete genomics and then go to the
project scope 19 where you can
learn how you can do different types of
analysis
once you have ngs data and how to
interpret those results
and once you are doing all these courses
and please complete all the assignments
so most of the assignment and analysis
that you are going to run
that is here so after learning or
performing multiple sequence alignment
in the next part of the project we will
move to the
variant data analysis so then you will
learn
how you can create reports on the
genomic
genomics sequencing data using custom
art script
so then in the under the genomics course
you will find some of the important
scripts
where you can learn how you can create
reports for the
different way uh variants of interest
so this kind of report you will able to
get
an end of running so once you have the
data in js data
then you can find what are the important
variants for example here number of the
uh variants that formed in the spike
protein are the three and here are the
different mutations so then in
each mute in each sample what are the
important mutation for each type of
protein subsequently you will
able to create this kind of plot so in
each sample
at which position a particular
nucleotides get mutated and apart from
that you will also get whether this
mutation is synonymous
or non-synonymous so in the next session
we are going to start with
multiple sequence alignment and how to
find data from the public repository
so now i would like pass this session to
dr mohit mazumdar
to talk about uh the upcoming program
for this complete course so over to you
dr mohit
yeah thank you dr preet and i
kind of uh shared with maddie here
having a question so i think that's
clear okay great
so what i kind of wanted to start with
was the program but it has been
so much described in in such a detailed
manner and a
great manner by ilya and uh hurry doctor
free
so let me take you through the sessions
and maybe like very briefly i can tell
about the
second phase of the program which
includes the genomic
surveillance so the first program first
part of the program was
i think is very well described and you
got to know about
the techniques and the platforms that
you will be using in the program and yes
you don't have to finish all the
coursework right now but i mean
it's up to you how much of that you can
cover till the next session but
it would be nice if you can finish the
introductory courses
uh so that we can start with the basics
that we are planning to cover
for the entire program so we will be
starting from the very basic
of uh genomic uh
genomic technology and then take you
through this different uh
scripting and reporting and all of that
so yeah again let me try share my screen
one second please
yes and please as mojito is sharing his
screen
if anyone has any questions feel free to
put them
into the chat box and we will try to
address those questions today
so was it clear for everyone
what we are going to be starting with in
terms of the program what would be
the objective for the next session
i hope that mohit actually answered that
pretty clearly
yes mohit we can see your screen now
right thank you
so as i was saying that this entire
program and i think many of the
uh students and faculty of the beginners
who have joined
might have this question is that what is
this program who is this program for
so this program this omixlogic program
is designed for students it's designed
for faculty it's designed for beginners
it's designed for biologists
also for clinician and researchers who
are who are interested
in advancing their understanding of the
logic that is behind the analysis
of uh sas cove to genomic analysis
and also to understand the uh analysis
of variant of concern
and then to develop a workflow of uh
variant reporting
using uh the using curated data as we
heard from
dr harpreet and elia also about
different repositories that are there so
these depositories have clinical data
environmental sequencing data so this
all will be used in the program
again this program will not require you
to have
any background in coding or in
bioinformatics or in biostatistics
because we will be covering many of the
topics and
most of the materials that we have
prepared for the program are
will be available to you to go through
so you can learn what we are covering
and you can understand
uh uh how to do the analysis yourself
so i mean what is the basic need to go
through this program yes i mean
it would be great if you know the topics
related to cell and molecular biology
because those are the terminologies that
comes often
when we are doing these sort of uh
specialization sessions
and uh involving biostatistics and also
uh other scientific domains right and so
this
about the specialization i think this uh
this program is a specialization
for uh bioinformatics for insecure
diseases
in that program we cover different
aspects of uh
different aspects of virology but in
this program which is more specialized
for
sars scope 2 we unders we
are going to understand a few we have
few objectives
and that would be very much cleared i
wanted it to be very much clear in the
first session
because we are meeting for the first
time and we all are getting introduced
so in this program we together
will be working on data analysis tools
to
help detect viral genomes using ngs data
and then viral strain haplotypes if you
have heard about them
and then dr repeat they talked about
synonymous and non-synonymous
mutations uh so we will be understanding
this from the perspective of
you know file types so what are the ngs
file types like past queue
uh you might have heard of or fasta that
you surely
have heard of i guess and then applying
these into
a comparative analysis and understand uh
how does how does this matter and how
this information
is critical to do vaccine design or to
look for the principles of
antiviral drug design as well as to
develop
uh understanding of resistance from the
standard drugs
which includes also like uh antibody
resistance right so we have three
mentors
which uh today have presented and you
are free to reach out to us for any
questions so dr herpete is there
myself uh is uh will be available and
ilya is also available
so uh we will also put for put
the email address that you can reach out
to for
for you know if you have any questions
or if you're facing any issues we also
have a support team
uh uh with interns and community our
community manager
so please feel free to talk about and
discuss all of that
so uh in the next session which will be
about detecting viral genomes
and uh then and from animal and patient
samples so in this session we will be
using ngs data to find the pathogen
so we will be using obviously
bioinformatics pipeline and processing
steps
to structure genomic data and then you
will be learning about some of the
algorithms i mean that are used to
align these big data sets you will learn
about algorithms such as uh if you have
heard of bow tie
it's a popular algorithm for ngs
analysis and this data analysis
his star and then we will be working
about uh on
identification of sequences using ncbi
virus
uh virus database
and then extracting in reads information
from alignments multiple sequence
alignments that dr harpreet talked about
so this will be about the second session
so let me quickly take you to
all of the sessions that will be covered
in the program so that you have a clear
picture
of how this is going to be so the third
session
will be about extracting reads that did
not map to the host genome from fastq
files after alignment
visualizing how they align to a specific
genome from a
database of viral genome so there are
databases that we'll be exploring which
will be helpful for us
to understanding of genomic variance
variations
in short reads after that the first
part of this program uh it will be to
extract data and understand how data is
deposited and how we can utilize that
publicly available data because data is
being generated
every day and huge amount of data has
been generated for
especially when we talk about kovid 19
in the scovid19 pandemic
so in this session we will be finding
the right
genomic sequences we will be using ncbi
alignment to check the quality uh
check the quality quality and preparing
data for analysis
so this will be the session after that
which is the last session on the second
phase
for the first phase uh where we will be
going through
step-by-step overview of a pipeline that
is used to align sequence
translate tri-nucleotide segments into
amino acids
and then use the alignment for
phylogenetic analysis using these
so we also have example pipelines that
we have created for you
uh in on the tibia info platform and
using that you will be able to go
through
the example uh that we have put together
comparing
different coronavirus or uh sequences
so that would be a project that we will
be covering in this session
so now the second phase of the program
which is more focused on you know
genomic surveillance of
scope too and very much into the
research
of variance and like the effect of
variance and variance of concern what
are the different types of variants
so in this second phase we will be
learning about again
the relationships so the relationships
which we can understand from
phylogenetic analysis
uh using different sort of algorithms we
will understand the relationships by
uh by strain by population
and by host so there's a lot of data
available for each of these
studies to be conducted and then
analysis of variance so
how variants could be analyzed once you
have identified
that this is a variant of concern what
are the functional implications what are
the structural implications and the
association of structural analysis to
understand the function so how can you
correlate uh function structure with
function
and then i mean to give you a brief
understanding of how this is going to be
so the
the pre-processing or the processing of
this data
these data sets would require high
throughput
uh workflows such as these so i
discussed with you
the algorithm some of the algorithms
that we will be using
so now in this workflows bioinformatics
workflows
uh it is essential to which are
essential for this
sort of analysis we will be also
utilizing the
r package so our statistical language
that has a rich library of tools and
functions that are available at
bioconductor and also github
will be utilized in this program so once
we have the analysis
how do you go to and from analysis to
pre-processing and understanding that
significance of that analysis so all
these relationships and
what data has been uh generated i mean
we have a clear understanding of what
biomass
bioinformatics methods are capable of
after working
for so long on different types of uh
data that has been deposited all around
the world so bioinformatics methods
could help us find individual mutations
then we can do sequence alignment that
come that could combine with
evolutionary models
that can track the changes in the
genomic sequences
and then link them to a process so this
m these models
uh they fit to thousands of genome and
they reveal
this dynamic tree of the pandemic which
shows the virus
that continues to change the noble it
continues to change into different
clades that separates it from the common
origin
and that has been seen in this like this
is a free resource
that we'll be covering in the session
that you'll get to see
so um yeah so this will be
also understanding of how different
mutations are originating from different
geographic locations so as i was telling
you that
we would be also discussing few of the
case studies so wastewater sequencing
is one of the projects so in this
project we will be utilizing pipelines
for
processing and then what happened in
this project is that
that our team was able to study in this
project
about the genomic variations in the
samples that we collected
uh an identified mutation
so since the data was collected over
time in this in this project over
several months
this analysis revealed important
information about viral transmission
amongst
students in comparison to the rest of
the city so it's a
project driven by lsu and primarily
the primary results uh it really
encouraged us to seek for
uh more funding to work on this so
to identify the noble
strain that are emerging that could that
like actually help the whole city
and benefit and so it's a genomic
surveillance that
is being utilized so this will allow i
mean local and regional governments
to develop mitigation strategies that
have been used to show
that has been shown to be successfully
uh implemented at lsu
based on the pcr testing so this is one
of the case study that we will be
covering
and then as i was saying as i was
telling you and doctor we did showed us
the uh tutorial and we have prepared
also tutorial and resources uh for the
participants to guide them to create
a report to analyze variants using
genomic sequences
uh sequencing data and then cloud
processing
and then custom r script so the second
phase
this is designed into several sessions
so do i mean
i i get that many of us get overwhelmed
with all of this information but they
are described
in sessions that will be happening
bi-weekly so you will get
ample enough amount of time to go
through the
material that has been shared the live
session and the recordings will be also
shared for you to review them
at your own time at your own pace so
uh as i was saying that uh we will be
covering them
through different sessions uh so this
will include hands-on sessions where
we'll be working on
clinical and environmental sequencing
and to understand this like
the projects that you are thinking about
so different type of datasets as i said
earlier also the different types of
datasets from patients
have been collected and categorized
based on age
based on pre-existing conditions social
habits
lifestyle climate location so there are
several
of these factors that are involved um
social economical background when it
comes to kobe 19.
so i think those are the factors that
are that
considering and then about correlating
the structures the sequence
and the evolutionary analysis and then
mutations
and the conservations and the viral
evolution
modeling the relationship between the
sequence based on probabilities
so we will be talking about phylogenetic
analysis evolutionary analysis and
conservation so it is very important in
the context of understanding the
behavior of the virus or to understand
about the variations
are what what are the guiding factors
behind them and then after learning
about all of this
obviously we discussed this over and
over that the scripting that is involved
to generate a report
but after that i mean uh sorry for that
sorry sorry about that
so after that we will be talking about
the interpretation of a molecular level
effect of these missing variations or
variance
which is indeed challenging and requires
this requires an investigation at an
amino acid substitution level so we will
be talking about the protein structure
which is really fascinating
we'll be learning about the 3d uh three
dimensional
uh how do we look at the
three-dimensional structure
how do we identify those mutation in the
in the three-dimensional structure
so what kind of questions that are that
we are going to answer so
we are going to answer questions like is
a variant
changing a site involved in key
molecular interactions
that has a key correlation with the
change in the function
for example i mean if a a mutation
is at a bank as at a binding site or
is at a place which is critically
involved in interaction
i mean what would be the effect so is a
variant changing an amino acid located
at a protein course or is a part of a
cluster
known to have pathogenic mutations in
benue 3
when you see them in three dimension
models
so these are some of the questions that
are really
interesting to learn from and from
genomic
when you can from genomic analysis if
you can trace back to the structure
that is a very satisfactory analysis
because you're understanding from a very
basic
from a very uh sequence level
understanding to
your reaching to a level where you're
going for a
structural level analysis and you're
correlating it to the function
and then you're giving a clear story so
i mean the future expectations we will
discuss that as well
so in that i mean we will discuss
how this different countries are using
this in and investing
billions of dollars in sequencing
variant detection
vaccination so what would be the
strategies based on this for sasko
and um about that i mean there has been
a lot of
uh a lot of news and some of these old
news that you see
is that many of the i mean all of the
government so in early
february u.s laboratories were only
sequencing about eight
thousand uh kobe 19 strains per week
and since then the rate of sequencing
has increased substantially
i mean strengthening the country's
ability to detect and respond to the
emerging and more contagious
contagious cohen ending strains like the
variants
currently sweeping the uh midwest and
the part of east coast
so to do that like the biden
administration have already made a
nearly about
uh 200 million investment to help
increase the genomic sequencing from 8
000 to 29 000 sample per week and
thanks to the funding from american
rescue plan
and then cvc is involved so
we would get an understanding of
increased geographical coverage of
sequencing to better understand these
and detect these emerging uh threats
like variants
so i mean this means that both existing
and new covet variants
could be detected faster before they
grow prevalent
so this is some of the
this on the application of this sort of
analysis and the
understanding the importance and the
skill sets that are involved in learning
this so i think
it it holds a lot of importance in
today's world
um and now i mean this is what i wanted
to tell you all
and before i kind of uh wanted to answer
a few questions that are out there
one of the question was about career
about like opportunities
about how do we go about to the next
step after learning this
so i would want to take you to this
linkedin group that we have where we
keep on posting
about job opportunities about internship
opportunities
about industry related opportunities
where you can like go and work because
we have a lot of
a lot of participants a lot of
collaborators from industry
who would look for specific skill sets
uh related to
these sort of understanding of detailed
understanding of
maybe genetic data maybe clinical data
and all of that
so i usually get a lot of queries from
our collaborators who are maybe ceos and
all of them
uh would ask that if if you have a
student who would be
interested in joining in some of our
projects so having a good profile
and then joining uh some of these groups
would give give you that information
what is out there
so maybe i would request celia or um
anyone else
or maybe ogsweet to share the link of
the linkedin group
and similarly i mean as i was telling
you about the linkedin group similarly
if you're on facebook
we have a group on facebook as well
where we keep on posting about the
upcoming programs and you've got to
learn about
what's going on and who's joining and
who's what and
uh what are the opportunities that that
that are there and
what are the projects that are ongoing
so this is an important
aspect i mean that is there with this
training
is to be able to collaborate with other
people i mean we have a very rich
bioinformatics research community and
that actually helps us to uh collaborate
with
a variety of researchers who are working
on different areas of research so if you
have
a research interest and and maybe if it
is being shared by someone else
it's always great to work on
uh work on a group project you get
results
pretty quickly you have a diverse
mindset that can come up with different
ideas
so those are some of the opportunities
that i would want to
encourage all of you to take in the
coming days
once your training is like more or less
you're more confident about all of the
resources and have some experience
going through the example projects and
the courses that we have put together
so i think that's what that's all what i
wanted to tell
all of you about this program and i'll
be happy to
address any questions that you have
so you can see me now hello thank you
mohit
yes so this was a good overview of
upcoming sessions
and how all of you can join a few
questions that i see
the first question was
can we also predict what kind of genetic
modification might be taken by the virus
based on the various environmental
factors or any other external factor
so briefly to answer that question
it's very important to know what is in
the data right so this program is going
to be focused on analysis
of available data if the data about
other factors like location
age environmental factors etc is
available
then in the program you will be able to
identify methods
to find some correlation now
as you can imagine association
does not always equal causality
so while we have some data there's also
probably a lot of data we don't have
and so that is really the challenge in a
lot of these bioinformatics projects
what is the available data so if you're
a part of the program
purabi you'll be able to share the data
sets and even find the data sets in
repositories that we will
showcase and if that data is available
then we will be able to discuss that in
detail
the second question was about
certification so maybe mohit you could
address that
okay let me check that i missed that
sorry
okay so about certification yep you see
a
and biswas is asking okay okay yeah
got it so in this program i mean there's
another
opportunity to get the certification by
completing the course so when you go
through and
finish introduction to bioinformatics
you get a pro
co-certification and by the end of the
program
we will give you an opportunity to
discuss and submit your research
proposal
as well as like if you participate and
finish all of the sessions
you get a certificate of participation
and once you submit your proposal
there's an opportunity to
get a certification of excellence which
you'll be sending out
otherwise but you will get your
certifications once you complete the
sessions and
earn points by completing the task
so if once you complete each of the each
of the
you know tasks and assignments you get
point
for doing that you get points to
complete the sessions also
to interact and to do the interactive
to be a part of the interactive session
and uh
you can complete that like once you like
today's session is done
so you can do that uh by completing
uh clicking the complete button so in
that sense
uh you get points and also like you kind
of let us know that you have gone
through this
uh gone through the session have
completed the session
other than that i mean there are several
courses
uh that gives you certification so you
will be you will have an opportunity to
earn a lot of certifications
using this one single program that's
what i'm coming at so
there are opportunities to get
certifications from different courses
and then there's this certification for
the program that you are part of
exactly so here under your profile you
will find
all of your certificates so you can see
program certificates or course
certificates
the way to get a program certificate is
on the program page to complete
the session so today we had our first
session if you're a part of the program
you can click on
complete session and then you will see
session completed that adds
towards your certificate so now you can
see down at the bottom
one out of 10 sessions complete so once
you complete all of the ten sessions
then you will be able to get your
program certificate
in the program we have a number of
different courses included
and each one of these courses comes with
its own certificate
if you complete that you will have a
certificate for that pro
for that course
okay so um the other one how to obtain
the reference sequence or amino acid
sequence for a variant like
alpha or beta of source cove to as it is
not available in ncbi for analysis
studies
so that's an excellent point variants of
concern
are being tracked by multiple groups
one of those groups is a consortium
called spheres another one is a
consortium called pangolin
so we will take a look at exactly the
mutations it's actually combinations of
mutations that are being tracked
and in our second part of the program we
will actually
run analysis from raw sequencing reads
to identification of variants of concern
and then building a report
with all of the important variants that
are listed
on those websites which is publicly
being
reviewed by the consortium and then
posted and so we will guide you on how
to do that
so sasta kumar let me know that answers
your question
maddie is asking i had some logistics
question
such as how long will each zoom session
be so the zoom sessions are one hour so
we're
a little bit over time today is there a
place where we can tell that
asynchronous course work we should have
done by each live session
so in the schedule you will find
information
on what topic will be covered and in
the session itself we will discuss what
are the specific
courses that you can get started with
now we know that many of you
are coming with different level
of bioinformatics already
understanding of molecular biology
understanding of source code two
sequencing approaches
so that is something that we are doing
today in today's session
maybe we can pause here and actually
ask everyone to share a little bit about
yourselves
and i will tell you what is the best way
to share that information with
us so as was already
meant mentioned by dr harpreet we have
this course called
introduction to bioinformatics and
in this course why we ask everybody to
complete this course
is because one of the first things that
you get to do is to fill out a form
about your background and current
occupation as well as location and
things like that and what you are
interested
in so if everyone could take a look at
this course
and submit this form we will analyze
the results from this form and
appropriately to your level of
background
recommend some coursework that you can
finish
so that by next time you are ready but
in general
we do recommend finishing introduction
to bioinformatics
bytes and molecules and start looking at
this course called
source code 2. you obviously don't have
to finish
if you do at least one of these courses
that will be great by next time
so please let me know maddie if that
answers your question
okay olivia um you have a tb info demo
user access it will be enough for the
program assignments
you will get access to the educational
version of the license
by next time so everyone who has
joined today this session after today's
session we will review everybody's
accounts because the registration is
still open
so you will have time to complete the
registration by
by our next session and we ask
that if you are not registered yet
that you actually complete that
registration and that will
give us the ability to issue different
levels
of account access so
we will have our next session on
july 16th
okay okay are there any other questions
all right excellent so um maybe i could
ask
uh from all of you that are present here
today
if you have gotten access to
the slack channel please
let me know if you have any technical
questions that would be the best way to
interact with us
is post your questions on the slack
channel
and we will review those so that we can
address any questions that you have
apart from that you can always reach out
to
marketing at pine.bio
mojit pine dot bio
support find out bio
and helia prime dot bio
please feel free to reach out to us and
we look forward to interacting with you
helping you along the way with this
program and we're excited to get started
thank you
thank you everyone have a nice
week